hello and welcome to this video playing
no guy something like that I am ok re
not begun yet ok let's play the slow
sloth and see how I share with this line
it's not popular at all on the
professional level but I don't think
it's so bad white sometimes has ideas
here with we just goes back don't see
that too often ok so hmm should be for
here maybe Bishop takes Bishop c6
you should work
it should takes before Bishop c6 then
queen takes before maybe this is a
little something for white
taking a long time out here not quite
there's some big hole here 94 maybe or
something I don't know maybe there was
some trick it's really it's possible
okay so I teak now on c6 it's where it's
quite lame but still probably correct I
don't see how I can get anything without
it
my place is solely based on the fact
that I'm a little bit quicker on the C
file and his Bishop is not the most
active piece it's very little it should
be very threatening that same for for
him okay um Bishop a4 may be coming
yeppity-do mind to Queen a three here I
don't don't think some eyes actually he
is quick enough he just has group c 8
and the only interesting movie is
grouped to c5 maybe maybe this is still
kind of interesting he cannot take yeah
okay it it's not not brilliant just
Bishop this seven probably
or that one k is there some way some way
two eyes got 97 coming up
now you probably just take pawn takes us
into more and more fighting move but I
don't don't believe it subjectively good
anyway but let's let's see if I can get
some kind of some kind of play going
night a for loop see to my original plan
doesn't work I wanted to go rook c to c
8 b 3 but yes rook takes split sort
orders is wrong words so not very
pleasant actually yeah it's got b6 now I
should have just played the normal stuff
as usual if you try something where
there's just a draw you get into some
some kind of yeah do you set yourself
problems more than that kb 693 is still
ok i guess it's not great down
yeah let's see pawn takes problem
and what's that a good decision now that
I think of it got my doubts
you
and as the bishop somewhat uncomfortable
to play against it can easily happen
that I lose the sea porn at porn is not
not as not a strength here at all
it should be a draw
let's see how to do this time morning
there's no way winning is impossible
here I just keep this bra offered it's
just wrong drawn okay so yeah that
wasn't really great I thought that might
have a little something here with the C
file and so on I defended that very
precisely it seems and then probably I
didn't didn't didn't play the most
testing moves but it's all very precise
going back for 97 now taking I should
just take with the rook now this is just
objectively best and just be okay with
this draw like rook c8 and then just
take it and it's totally equal i'd
rather be black but it's it's not it's
not something that is this quite
threatening i actually could have taken
didn't see that idea so we would have
had to take here and yeah okay let's
it's probably an easier draw then then
this where i really have some doubts
yeah even up to here if he if he does
not take on b3 like this then this isn't
isn't good at all I don't have a clear
spot to go to I mean if i go here for
example just a six-mile a bad night is
just not good it cannot go anywhere and
i'm losing this pawn him i was happy
that he did that I think he I'm here to
draw probably not even though King c7
this is a draw but King c7 maybe but
okay if I go here King b6 they are key
he was here right he's not taking yeah
I'm still roseum yeah kem here there's a
really clean draw yeah I should take
with the Brooklyn taking what the pawn
is just them it's not a positive play I
mean I'm rather worse and I should just
just take c8 and be okay with having
nothing yeah that's the best the better
choice okay well thanks for watching